um
you obviously are
very distinct you're very unique in your
delivery i feel like uh in a world in
which we have so many artists that sound
alike or at least very you know
influenced by each other i feel like
you're kind of quite the opposite um
who would you say you grab inspiration
from whether it's old heads or you know
[ __ ] you've grown up growing up
listening to or new [ __ ] um
it really like bounced around like my
number one inspiration
in music from when it came to me like at
a time when i needed it was like a group
called little dragon little dragon from
gothenburg sweden bros like my favorite
group in the world
world yeah like i was going through
something crazy and i founded music and
it
helped me even become a better writer
better is the music in english or is it
in english and it's super soulful you
know what i'm saying it's pop funky it's
not like rap [ __ ] but it's
grey sounds and and then of course like
all the the mega hip-hop
people we know of course jay-z like lil
wayne like these are my like
i'm curious who's who's on you're like
mount rushmore
like give me your five like no no order
you don't got to give me the order
because that's where things get kind of
hairy where you're like jazzy wayne okay
okay it says one
little dragon and
sliding the family stone or d'angelo
like they're super okay we're talking
about mc's here oh we gotta talk about
rap yeah we're trying to rap okay
straight rap
so jay-z wayne outcast is one
um
now it gets tricky right it does get
tricky yeah wayne hove outcast so far
you're three for three a little swisher
earl sweatshirt it's kind of crazy right
wow
[Music]
um
it's tough i don't even know yeah one
more i know you gotta feel that thinking
like a lot of names
look at the names on the wall like
what are some names going through your
head like thug like okay like uh k-dot
of course
yeah um
it's different vibes
y'all seen bae like there's so many
people that i just like love so much
yeah you have